q
j'ai intégré erp cannes en 2010 est
recalé le centre de recherche de la
filière canne sucre à la réunion
le coeur de métier berkane et la
création variétale
il existe également le service de
procéder et innovations industrielles
dont une des missions est la recherche
de nouvelles valorisation des coproduits
de l'industrie sucrière
par exemple la bagasse qui est la partie
fibreuse de la canne à sucre la mélasse
ou encore les écumes qui sont utilisés
comme on peut
et
à l'heure actuelle seuls 20% de la canne
à sucre est utilisé ma mission consiste
plus particulièrement à développer une
nouvelle valorisation des coproduits de
la filière parce qu'il s'agit d'un
travail en laboratoire
tout d'abord nous analysons et nous
identifions les molécules à valoriser
puis nous développons des méthodes
d'extraction afin de les valoriser à
l'échelle industrielle
nous travaillons sur un projet de
valorisation des sires de cannes qui
peuvent être utilisés dans le domaine de
la cosmétique
ce dont je suis fier c'est de travailler
sur des projets d'avenir qui vont
apporter de nouvelles perspectives à la
filière canne et plus largement à la
réunion
ce qui me plaît dans ce métier et qu'on
ne sait jamais à quoi s'attendre
c'est un travail de longue haleine on
avance à petits pas et on obtient
souvent un résultat positif ce qui me
plaît c'est l'innovation et la
découverte
non